hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm monster on a world
again we have the second solo guide of
the day today and today's gonna be on
bayit Otis or Baio Bo I'm gonna call
them Bo for the rest of the video if you
actually know how to pronounce this guy
let me know in the comments below I
struggle with trying to mention any of
these damn monsters in these videos I
mean I think I had Oda Garen completely
wrong I think I said his name wrong for
like four months straight so I'm pretty
[ __ ] at this as always I need to preface
this in all these videos I know it says
that this is the beta and as I'm making
this video it is the beta of Monster
Hunter ice born on ps4 but if this video
is still up and you are watching and
during the full release of ice born in
September do not worry that means that
the monster hasn't changed drastically
or hasn't changed at all since the beta
so this is still up to date so don't
worry about that if he happens to be
changed this video wouldn't even exist
and you probably wouldn't even be
hearing this audio because the video
would be gone and I'd be making another
guide for it and also keep in mind I
cannot do the physiology report looking
at the weaknesses I have to go based off
of my gameplay I also keep in mind I
cannot show the physiology report
because there is not one currently in
the beta but if there is happens there's
obviously going to be one in the full
game or if somebody happens to figure it
out before the full game releases I will
leave it in the comments below in a pink
comment so always check the comments
just in case that is there but with that
let's continue on with today's video
like the V if you do enjoy and let's get
started so be who is your typical fish
monster kind of like Lovaas e auth and I
think his name is gira I basically like
that but with snow very nice
introduction to monster on ice born but
you can actually go under the snow and
swim towards you at face value it seems
like he has no weak point but once you
damaged his snow armor it breaks off and
then you can hit it for full damage this
is on the head the stomach area and then
on the tail as well that also seems like
his horn it can be broken or possibly
severed as well but I wasn't able to
achieve this and same as bon burrow in
this beta poison and paralysis knives
are given to you and they can work after
four hits and I'm assuming sleep can
also as well but there wasn't any silly
of items for me since I was using the
dual blade so I cannot confirm this B
LOC is this dolphin move where he goes
underneath and then pops out I've never
been hit by this I'm not even sure if
you're even supposed to be hit by this
he always dives and ends up landing a
little bit away from me so this really
isn't that issue I guess he's just
trying to get closer to you because I
know
been hit by this before just like Lavasa
album bro and many others in the game he
has the standard tail swipe and the
thrust moving you get to close but he
also has a belly flop move where he
slams his stomach on the ground near you
this won't be defeating you in terms of
attacks and you won't be carted but this
damage can add up over time if you're
not careful so just do be aware and keep
an eye on your health bar just in case
it does a lot of damage he also seems to
have a hammer spike attack which will
only damage you from the front he'll
look straight ahead of you and then he
will jump up in the air and slam his
head on the ground if you're on the
sides of him or behind him this will
completely negate the attack entirely
and won't do any damage to you so keep
that in mind he also has this eruption
move like Diablos where he goes
underground and pops back up I'm not I'm
very unsure if the screamer pods
actually work very similar to Diablo
since the baited in heaven II but let me
know in the comments below if this does
work for you he will at some point
trying to go underground and then spin
to get his snow armor back either stop
him before he does this or knock it off
of him again to get rid of it very
simple he seems to act like kind of gira
but instead of water it's snow so that
can kind of help you to prepare for this
fight since we've constantly fought him
in Lavasa off a lot recently since of
course the full game has been out for
months almost more than a year he also
seems to only activate traps when above
ground and not in the snows also keep
that in mind just in case he's coming
toward you and other than that he's
basically a pretty simple monster and as
usual he's most likely gonna be tranqued
and captured since he's down an elder
dragon so if you want more materials and
you want to skate part of the ending of
the fight you can always do that and
yeah as usual once you do enough damage
he'll crawl over to his nest go to bed
and then you can do that extra sleep
damage on him as well use your most
powerful attack or if you're like me and
have dual blades you might as well just
use a barrel bomb because that's gonna
be your most damaging move anyway
and just like every other monster in
this game and especially when the clutch
got officially releases the clutch call
of course does work on a bo here as well
you do have to be aware though the
problem with at least with bomb bro is
that he can knock you off sometimes at
some of his moves and especially T jerks
and really knock you off it doesn't
really seem like Bo can actually knock
you off as much with many of his moves
at least when I was using the clutch
call and nine times out of ten I was
still getting stuck onto him I wasn't
being knocked off so I think he's a
pretty safe monster to be using that
move for me other than that that's
really it
this monster wasn't too difficult to be
fair and even if he happens to do way
more damage in the full game because
this is obviously the beta and he's
going to be a master rank monster even
if he does some extraordinary amounts of
damage I don't think he's gonna be too
big of a deal honestly I think this
monster is pretty basic to fight yeah
let me know how you guys are enjoying
the beta or if this is the full game of
course I'm gonna hire enjoying the
monster regardless I think Bo is
probably my favorite so far - this beta
I think is really fun to fight and I
kind of like fighting these type of fish
going in inside the environment type
monsters like Leviathan gira yeah I'd
like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I covered the
solo guides of monster hunter world I've
covered majority of the base characters
within the game and I'm also gonna be
covering majority of the monsters in
ice-born so definitely keep an eye on
that we got bomb bro as my recent video
I got this one I got a tigress video
coming out in an hour so and then I also
I'm going to be covering volcano who's
the elder dragon of the game and any
other monster in between it happens to
or at least that we have no idea about
I'll definitely keep you guys covered on
that to make sure that everyone knows
how to defeat these monsters so we can
farm them a lot easier and get their
gear my two most recent videos are gonna
be popping up on screen as well that's
going to be the guides for the monsters
within with the beta so definitely go
check that off you're having a little
bit of trouble or if you're just trying
to prep for one monster on our ice barn
releases so you can breeze through these
guys within minutes I mean that guys
have a great stir day enjoy the rest
your video enjoy the beta wallets out
and peace out
you